okay welcome everyone thank you very
much for coming I'm Danny citta Marion I
am a twin and actually my twin brother
is here along with his girlfriend so
these are two of my best friends in the
world so thank you very much for coming
but also you are my friends as well so
thank you for coming to the talk yes
like he said I'm a full-stack data
scientist I love researching machine
learning problems being creative with
data and deploying solutions to the
cloud or whatever I'm Spanish and
American and I love working on problems
that impact and improve our society and
our environments and our people I also
love the DIY ethic so this is part of
the reason I started making this package
and contributing and learning from the
open-source community so I am like you
said is a new library for fitting
journalized additive models in Python
it's I've tried to make it really
modular it's written in pure Python
which makes it easy to deploy and
integrate into your work stream and it
plays nice with the rest of the PI data
stack so it's easy to if you know a
scikit-learn it should look familiar
the fit and predict methods are all
similar it integrates with a grid search
and the randomized search and it's also
very easy to extend the typical
regression and logistic models with
custom link functions and custom
distributions so this is part of the
modularity that's that I've tried to
start and make it easy to extend as well
so if you want to contribute it's quite
easy so if you're familiar with our
you've probably heard of the mg CD
package their gams are actually quite
popular in our programming language and
there's some excellent packages out
there they're written by the people who
develop a theory for generalized
additive models so the quality is
amazing and I encourage you to use it
and in fact there's a talk later today
about how to interface our and Python so
why would you even bother to come here
there's also a different package in
Python called pi earth that implements
the Mars algorithm but when it comes to
flu fitting penalized regression splines
in Python there was no package so I
decided to step in and can show you back
to the open source community on top of
giving there's also a lot of receiving
so I get to learn a lot about
statistical theory and
improve my code quality as well as learn
about how it is to contribute to an
open-source project and what type of
responsibility that brings with it
there's tons and tons of awesome parts
of the Python pip PI again package that
would love to talk to you about but we
have so little time so I can only talk
about a handful of them and really we're
gonna focus on a regression task and I
think the most the easiest way to
illustrate these properties is with an
example so suppose that you know we're
here at PI data and we have our own
self-sufficient community we're gonna
call it PI data topless and one of our
tasks in our community is to generate
our own electricity so what we have to
do is be aware and be prepared for the
worst case scenario so we should plan
how much o2 s'ti we need to generate for
tomorrow or for the days of the head if
we generate too little we risk a
blackout and if we generate too much
then we're wasting our precious
resources so since we're at PI data we
decide the best way I do this is with
machine learning and we're gonna be
data-driven so we collect a data set a
historical data set and you know we can
see a we collected data set that has
kilowatts for the building the outside
air temperature as well as a couch
coverage because we believe that the
environmental effects are going to have
some influence on the on the predict on
the power that our building requires so
we look at the power for the building
and we see a couple of things there's
this kind of repeating pattern which is
the weekly cycle and then also this sort
of trend that's going from high in the
beginning to low at the end so maybe in
the beginning of the year in 2010 for
some reason the building was less
efficient and was using more electricity
and towards the end the trend the
baseline of the building was using less
but then there's also this you know
multiplicative effect or towards the
middle half of the year the amplitude
increases so there's all these
interesting features in this dataset and
zooming in we see indeed this weekly
cycle so we have these five spikes and
then a rest period of two days so this
corresponds to the weekdays and then the
weekend so we go to our you know our
super-powerful machine learning toolbox
and we get our LST m/s or whatever
re/max nearest neighbors RBF SVM
whatever whatever whatever we make an
awesome model we get an amazing fit you
know so we're excited
so we go to the rest of the people up I
did a topless and we say we got it I got
them prediction for tomorrow here you go
but our friends are skeptical and they
start asking a lot of questions and
they're like okay so how sure are you
that this prediction is correct you know
it's quite a big deal if you know you
predict too low the building will shut
off and if you predict too much we're
wasting our energy you should really be
giving me an interval that way I can
prepare against the worst-case scenario
that's a good question
someone else says you know did you even
bother looking at the weather for this
of the year it's gonna be a hot summer
how does weather influence the powers
our building requires how should we
prepare for this hot summer weather okay
good question as well someone else says
what about the cloud coverage I want to
know about that does that influence and
someone else just literally asks etc so
all these people are asking random
questions so you go back to your tool
box and you try to evaluate all right my
linear models will that be perfect just
as interprete Buhl's I need I can just
look at the coefficients and decide what
influence it's going to have an output
but there's too much bias they're not
flexible enough to fit my data and all
of the powerful models I have are cannot
be decomposed they're black boxes Theory
Maxwell that's a maybe that's an in
between you know classical time series
method but at the end of the day it just
gives me a bunch of coefficients out and
I don't know what to do with those
so you just spend some time surfing the
internet and you read a blog post about
gams and it sounds interesting because
it says that the prediction is based off
a bunch of independent feature functions
that are added together so you can
inspect the contribution of from each
feature sounds interesting
so you pip install PI again okay cool so
now we take the data set add a couple of
dummy features for example the day of
the week because we thought that this
was a pattern that we identified and a
time of the year because we want to
perhaps fit a trend we instantiate it
just like we would our scikit-learn the
thing and we say gam fit X Y cool looks
pretty reasonable you know this is our
prediction this is our target data
looks pretty reasonable I mean there's a
couple of differences but the overall
trend is there all right not too bad so
we look in the documentation and we say
I want to see what these feature
functions are all about how does it
depend how does my output depend on the
inputs so we check the documentation and
we say partial dependence functions
that's exactly what I want get me the
dependence functions and a confidence
interval around them cool so already we
see that day of the week feature that we
identified is kind of there you know
these five lumps and a two two day rest
modulus whatever day of the week we see
that yearly trend which started high and
ends low kind of like we identified and
here we have the two weather variables
that we saw this kind of quadratic
dependence on temperature that's
interesting so we can already answer
that one person's question and then this
other cloud cover we have no idea what's
going on there what the hell is that
okay so this day of the week thing looks
cool but it might be too smooth right
let's try to change the default let's
add a hundred splines for that feature
looks okay I mean looks fine I don't
know what to do about that looks cool
great can we answer this first person's
question about the uncertainty it turns
out that yes we can just give them a
confidence I'm sorry we can give them a
prediction interval so we plot that our
average prediction as well as a
prediction interval around it and here's
the target for the next couple of days
we got lucky we always guessed an
interval that contains the actual
prediction that contains the actual data
this doesn't always happen but we got
lucky so great we satisfied two of the
questions but we still have some open
questions namely how do we choose the
correct amount of smoothness we did this
super arbitrarily right we said give me
100 splines until it looks more or less
right how do you do this in a
disciplined way and what can we do about
that cloud coverage feature can we do
some sort of feature selection cool so I
guess let's let's take a moment and step
aside well answer those questions later
what are gams whoops
this is at your question okay so who
here has ever fit a linear model awesome
who here has ever fit gamma do more than
I expected but it turns out that
everyone that's fit a linear model of
four has also faded generalized additive
models because it's a specific case for
the sake of this talk we're going to
refer to generalized linear models as
linear models just for the sake of
simplicity so once again who here has
ever fit a generalized additive model
nice alright cool so let's recap a
linear model as we know it fits one
coefficient per dimension of our feature
vector so at the end of the day what we
have is one line per feature and we can
sum them together and make a prediction
a generalized additive model is quite
similar but instead of that instead of a
line we fit a possibly nonlinear
function on each feature this is in the
most this is in the simplest regression
case in general our feature functions
can have interactions of features which
in practice is often important right
like we need to know in one region of
feature space the function to do
something in a different region feature
space that you do something different
but we're going to restrict ourselves to
the simple case and regression at that
realistically gams can also model any
exponential family distribution on the
error and as well as link functions but
we're going to constrain ourselves to
the regression case if we take you know
our whole machine learning toolbox and
we organize them by predictive power and
interpretability we might get something
like this modulus the fact that I have a
point to prove here so we'll we'll see
you know our predictive and
uninterpretable neural networks on one
hand of course if you have a multi-layer
perceptron and you alter one feature of
the input neurons you have almost no
idea what it's going to do to the output
especially especially when you move to a
different region of feature space
perhaps in one region and increases the
output and a different region changing
your input decreases the output it's a
quite a black box right same thing goes
for our BFS with svms
and some of your other favorite powerful
tools linear models on the other hands
super interpret all right you just look
at the coefficients but they're they
have quite high bias on
time's it turns out that games are just
linear models so they have just as
interpret the same interpret ability as
linear model and almost say - predictive
power this this slightly lower pretty
much power is actually a gift because
it's what makes our models so
interruptible so what is again it's an
extension of a GL m and it all it does
is it adds splines and a smoothing
penalty welcome to a smoothing penalty
later a spline is a function with that
is non zero on a very small interval and
it's built out of low degree polynomials
so the simplest spline is just this box
function and there's this really cool
property which is that if you convolve
if you convolve splines you get a spline
of one degree higher so we do come Bal
these two box functions and we get a
spine of degree one the cool thing is
that this spline has a continuous zeroth
derivative right it's a continuous
function so what we'll see in general is
that a spline of degree M has continuous
zero oops has continuous n minus 1
derivatives and this yeah it also has n
minus 1 segments n plus one segments so
we convolve the two linear function the
two linear splines and we get a degree
two we convolve those two and we get a
degree three here we stop it turns out
you know in practice a third degree
spline is as smooth as we need to get
for things to be visually appealing
there's a cool property is this one as
well which is that they have like we
said continuous second derivative so no
matter how many of these degree three
splines we add together the overall
function will have a continuous second
derivative in the limit if we keep
composing splines like this the limit is
a Gaussian and it kind of makes sense
right the a Gaussian has infinite
derivatives and we would expect that a
function that has of degree a spline of
degree infinity would have infinity
minus one derivatives which is infinity
right so intuitively it seems satisfying
cool so now that we know how to build a
spline let's see how we actually build
these nonlinear functions we take our
splines and we lay them out in a grid
and then we give them each their own
coefficient so a different weighting and
then we add them up and that's our
feature function
I'm gonna try to convince you that this
function even though it looks nonlinear
we can estimate it and fit it using
linear methods so let's take a look at
the most simple again a function of just
one feature with whatever normal error
you know so let's break this up like we
had like we said we have that sum of
spline functions each weighted with
their own coefficient but it turns out
that since we know those spline
functions a priori we can just evaluate
each spline function at the X right so
now that's bunk spline function value at
X we can just replace that with X hat
just pre compute them this sum is just
an inner product so now our function or
our functional form is the same as a
linear model so agam is just a big deal
in this is a big deal because it means
that we get a ton of statistical theory
for free we get to do model
introspection we know we can we get to
learn about our model variance the
uncertainty we have in our predictions
we can extend it to a bunch of stuff
blah blah blah we get a lot of physical
theory for free this is a big deal
everyone gets a machine-learning and
then we get a lot of specific GAM things
for free as well we can we get an
intuitive regularization parameter which
is called smoothing and we get you know
the ability to model nonlinearities
automatically cool just can't so games
are great right they have all these
great properties so coming back to
smoothing how do you do that let's go
back to this you know this example so we
chose the number of splines that's
moving stuff totally arbitrarily till it
look nice huh what we were trying to do
really in that example well let's go
back to that so look at the outside air
temperature this one in the bottom left
corner it has um it's quite Wiggly right
like it's got an overall quadratic kind
of looking shape but why is it so Wiggly
like is that wiggliness
you know significant is it really
important for our predictions same thing
with like the yearly trend right like
what are what's up with all that can we
smooth that out more should it be less
smooth and the cloud coverage the
confidence interval around that is quite
wide so why is all this wiggliness in
there can we just eliminate that stuff
it turns out that we can
we can be a little bit more disciplined
about the definition of wig leanness and
we can quantify it like this by taking
the squared the integral of the square
of the second derivative it kind of
makes sense right because the second
derivative measures curvature so if we
square that we always get a positive
number this way negative curvature and
positive curvature have the same effect
and then we integrate that mmm so now
our our objective is that linear
objective that we saw earlier from the
model from the linear model as well as
this wiggliness objective we can tune
how much we care about wiggliness with
this lambda parameter so a high lambda
means that we penalize wiggliness really
heavily and a low lambda if it's zero we
don't even care about it it turns out
that we can approximate the numerical
derivatives so we can approximate that
second derivative using numerical
methods this matrix s takes the
numerical derivatives and then we can
approximate and do the integration using
this quadratic inner product with the
beta's so this is our functional form if
we take if we look for the closed form
solution of this it's as follows and
this is kind of nice because it looks
familiar to the solution to Ridge
regression which is intuitively you know
satisfying we're not getting something
totally crazy with Kennel additive
models all right so how do you do this
in practice let's make some random data
blah
kind of cool you can kind of see like a
signal right this is a expanding
sinusoidal curve so let's let's try it
out we take a gam and we make it extra
flexible we put 50 splines in it so we
have you know the potential for a ton of
wiggliness tons of degrees of freedom in
here and we make a super high smoothing
penalty one million so we'd expect there
very high penalty on wiggliness and we
fit it and we get an almost a straight
line that makes sense right there's a
cool feature in pi again which is the
model summary and it gives you a bunch
of information one of the things i've
highlighted is this effective degrees of
freedom so out of those 50 smoothing
prep out of those 50 spline functions
this super massive smoothing parameter
of a million has crushed the flexibility
of the model to just a straight line so
that's nice let's go the opposite way
right let's make the lambda 1 over 1
million so we have almost a zero
smoothing parameter
now we get something that's the opposite
end of the spectrum you know the left
side is like clearly just fitting noise
and just the variance in the noise we
would not want our fit to be like that
and if we look at the model summary we
get a model that's indeed almost as
flexible as as the potential as the
number of signs we had okay so those
smoothing penalty is kind of doing its
job so how do we do the right amount of
smoothing let me take a drink of water
well the obvious choice is
cross-validation right it's been up
there for a few seconds so right since
our since our generalized additive
models are an extension of linear models
we get to do generalized cross
validation which is a superfast linear
algebra approximation to leave one out
cross validation this is great it means
that we don't have to do this tedious
you know split everything into folds
take the average of the loss across the
folds find the the parameter setting
with the lowest loss take that for
granted we can just evaluate each model
one time and get this GCB score hyper
pramod optimization this smoothing
parameter selection is not an
afterthought in pi again all you have to
do is replace the fit function with this
grid search and if you want to be even
more specific you can specify the grid
at what you're looking so here we you
know specify 100 different functions 100
different parameter settings and we get
that the model decides that 25 degrees
of freedom is the best choice and it
looks quite nice too not too straight
not too Wiggly cool so we kind of know
how to do this let's go back to our PI
data topless our city or self-sufficient
City and let's choose the best that
choose the best model since we have four
features that we have one lambda
parameter per feature I in theory we
could smooth we can smooth the linear
the yearly trend very heavily while
keeping the weekly trend very flexible
right so we have four lambda parameters
this is a four dimensional search space
it would make our grid search really
infeasible so instead we get a little
lazy what
choose a random search so I make a
randomly generate points in a 40 grid
and grid search across them and we get
something like this which kind of is a
lot nicer right all the wiggliness of
this temperature and of the yearly
Trender are eliminated it turns out that
the model decides that a more smooth day
of week predictor is better ok whatever
and all the way leanest have the cloud
coverage is out of there that's great
because it means yeah it didn't it
didn't look like it mattered right what
the confidence interval around that
cloud coverage is still really wide
what's going on with that so again we
turn back to model summary and we look
at the p values and the significance is
for each feature indeed the significance
for that feature is super tiny it
shouldn't matter at all right so we can
I guess the best thing to do is we just
eliminate that feature going forward but
I've kind of lied to you guys this whole
time I made that feature using random
data so of course it should be it should
choose as insignificant and in fact if
you look closely at the other P values
you'll see that they're all identical
right they all have this 1.11 eats I -16
this is actually something that we have
to change that's a bug in again so
that's an issue that you can check out
on the github in you know help out with
but there's also a lot of really cool
stuff right like there's all these cool
features I didn't get to but there's a
lot of awesome features that we still
have to add to make us library even more
powerful I what you know feature
interactions the reason we're focusing
on functions of just one feature at a
time is because so far we I don't have
that syntax I don't have the semantics
in there for the library and a bunch of
other really cool stuff that are just
gonna make it much better and so I
definitely encourage you yeah if if
you've been inspired by this talk check
out the github check out the issues
there's a bunch of good good first-time
contribution things whatever help out
yeah so thank you very much
thank you very much Danny I would have a
ton of questions to you but probably
offline let's give the audience the
chance okay hi Danny and thanks a lot
great presentation great program how
does it compare with profit which I'm
pretty sure you're also familiar with
because they are both gams yes yeah
what's your view on that
the second question more content-driven
is for your city how good is the weather
forecast and is weather really usable
because my experience is beyond let's
say the next four hours it's not so easy
and beyond the week it's or beyond two
days it's really random yeah yeah all
right great
I've used profit only a little bit the
profit is this generalized additive
model software for building time series
games and it's made by if the Facebook
team I only use it a little bit it was
it was kind of cool it has a bunch of
cool features for yeah for automatically
detecting change points in your time
series so it's got all those great
features and it's built for it's built
for time series so I guess this is both
a feature and a limitation of the
software I like as far as I can tell
it's not easy to adapt it to non time
series problems one of the other things
that you know it's it's going to have
very few bugs it's going to be very well
maintained that's a awesome plus one of
the things I don't like about it is the
API it's I think it's kind of kind of
clunky and especially coming from this
PI data scikit-learn API stuff I find
that way more intuitive and but honestly
it compares quite favorably
I was implementing these these time
series models that I was doing that was
showing you guys I was actually
implementing them at my previous company
and I was comparing both profit and
Pugin and I had a stake in PI game of
course but I was comparing both of them
and the prediction intervals were super
consistent between both of them so it
was a coin toss to me at the end of the
day and for your second question go
ahead
which was about the city that predicts
at the time the temperature of the city
right
correct forecasts are not very usable
yeah yeah sure the way that's the way
that I dealt with this I think in
practice oh yeah
well yeah I don't have a good answer for
you I'm sorry besides the fact of saying
this is a toy answer in fact there's
actually a lot of problems with the
example I gave you which is that of
course we're competing we did the grid
search for the best model using this
generalized cross validation score but
in fact that assumes that each sample is
iid you know identically distributed
whatever independent but in time series
are not so already we have this that
would actually not be the right cross
validation criteria for this specific
problem in theory we would really want
to use this kind of nested time series
type of cross validation yeah if I can
add to that very quickly answering a
question I actually did compare profit
and and gaps and I can tell you that the
cams combined with in an ensemble with
another method beat profit depending on
depending on maybe an application it was
either support vector regressions or or
random forests and it was actually an
ensemble okay any other questions
I thank you for this great talk I'm
gonna ask if generalized these two
models also suffer from the
multicollinearity yes that's a great
question so do these suffer from
collinearity and the features yes they
do in fact there's a specific measure
for for these types of models called
concavity that's another that's another
thing that we have to add to the package
as well and we could add into the
Diagnostics of the summary but yes and
they do suffer from this from this
problem and we have to you can estimate
the amount of the amount of collinearity
and then try to address your features
selection based on that as well but that
is a really good a really good statistic
that should get integrated to the
package as well
hi great top and great package you
answer thank you
maybe this is a dumb question but but I
can Camby so interpretable as a linear
model if your function if each feature
as a fun arbitrary function a potential
arbitrary function right the reason it's
so interpretable is because we are at
the end of the day only adding the these
nonlinear functions together so if we
were doing something more complex like
multiplying them and then in a second
layer doing a different transformation
on them like a neural network would do
then yes of course would be very
difficult to interpret but since we're
only doing a very simple operation to
combine these nonlinear functions
together which is just the summing
operation that's what keeps them so
interpretive all but do they have do
they those functions in this setting
operation have their own coefficients
right so write the formula is that we
for every feature we allow we allow
several splines and each spline gets its
own coefficient and then we add those
points together so but the thing is that
at any given point our our prediction
only depends on the sum of several
different feature functions so I want to
say how does my output depend on feature
one I would just look at the only
feature function that depends on feature
one which would be this this set of
splines one nonlinear function if I want
to see how my output depends on feature
two I would look at the only nonlinear
function that has feature two in it so
look at that spline function I hope
thank you for your talk check out your
package so I was two quick questions
yes the first one is I wonder if you
have ever been schmuck against my
Gaussian process libraries since GM and
Gaussian process mathematical they're
quite similar yes and the second
question is that in terms of line non
Gaussian noise is is PI gram also built
in to kind of handle these situations
yeah cool so I have not benchmark
against Kozmo process and like you said
that's it's a very beautiful
relationship that they share together
what I know for sure is that the
estimation is much faster for PI again
because you can just use it you
estimated using these squares whereas
for free Koster process is much more
complex but I guess of course yeah
anyways the long story short I have not
benchmarked them but it's a super good
question in fact I have hardly
benchmarked against officially I don't
have any benchmarks on the documentation
which would be which is missing as well
but it's a really good point and I
forget what the second question was oh
yes yeah I would like to show you
actually this is I didn't have enough
time this is one of the things I really
wanted to show you guys today but you
can easily fit functions with non
Gaussian noise so if you have whatever
regression problem is guess you know is
if you have a classification problem
this is binomial noise you can easily
fit Pike I'm using this we also have the
potential to fit plus R models using
Poisson distribution so you can do
histogram smoothing or model count data
like this and in general any family
exponential family distribution you can
model it in this software very easily
and very modular lis thank you good
opportunity okay
thank you for the talk I personally use
gum now and I started to use them with
with this package actually but I wanted
to ask if you compared my gum with mgcp
package in terms of performance yeah so
he's asking if I've compared pajama with
MDC v md cv I think in my opinion is
like the gold standard gam package
because it's written by one of the top
researchers in the world that studies
gams
Simon wood and in fact the whole package
that I wrote for pi gam is based on the
textbook that he wrote about gems so in
a sense um yeah it's heavily inspired by
the MT CD package and in fact it's it's
trying to be a clone in many ways and a
lot of the a lot of the tests I run are
comparing well what is how does my how
does the model summary perform against
the model summary the equivalent model
summary of the our package so I've only
compared it in that type of in that
respect but yes it's super inspired by
the mgcp package and can only hope to be
to be as good as it at some point but
also modular in its own way and
intuitive more intuitive to Python stack
users in its own way as well
if not thank you very much
this was a session on explain ability
and privacy thank you to Danny it once
again and I think we have a break now
don't we yes see you then
[Applause]